Jenny is with us in Houston Texas hi
Jenny welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave that scripture you just read is
very very fitting okay cool
how can I help so my husband and I are
really just needing to know our next
step we recently were our daughter was
diagnosed with a terminal terminally ill
in terminally ill and so she passed away
an hour after she was born and this was
just seven weeks ago well we live yeah
so we moved in with our my in-laws and
are just looking for you know how soon
do we need to buy our next house how
much should we spend those types of
questions
okay what did the move have to do with
the loss of your daughter I don't know
the connection yeah so when I was
pregnant with her early in the pregnancy
is when we found out something wasn't
right and so we didn't know if this
would be something that she could live
with but be severely disabled and so we
didn't know what kind of medical bills
we'd be looking at or if we would need
the help of our in-laws to take care of
our four-year-old son and be back and
forth to the hospital
so we've sold our house is our
flexibility for that okay in preparation
of the oncoming storm that makes sense
right
yes and I assume you've got money from
the sale of your house we did so we have
about 105 in cash and we don't have any
debt and this was seven weeks ago you
said yes sir very fresh 20:27
okay I'm so sorry
well other than just dealing with the
raw emotion that any normal human will
be dealing with in your situation and
I'm dealing with just listening to you
with grandbabies myself other than
dealing with that I mathematically or
financially I don't know why you
wouldn't
turn the page and just buy home and
start the next chapter of this journey
that your own called your life right and
that's not that's not to be
disrespectful to your daughter that
passed but it is the next chapter and
that is our reality that we sit in and
so I mean certainly some number of
months or years from now you won't be
living with your in-laws you will have a
life and a house right right and I guess
my question would just feel like we
don't know how much we want to spin and
I want to make sure we're not you know
jumping into something making an
emotional decision so yeah I would agree
with that and it's it's tough to make a
big decision in the midst of this much
pain and that's that's that that's the
only thing giving me pause here but
everything else is lined up and so the
guidelines that we use around here are
don't buy more house then you can put on
a 15-year fixed that is a fourth of your
take-home pay so what's your monthly
take-home pay about fifty five hundred
okay all right and so that tells us
we're in the twelve hundred fifteen
hundred dollar range on your monthly
take-home I mean on your house payment
on a 15 year fixed with a hundred
thousand dollars down right and and
you're debt-free I assume we are and so
we would save some of that for our three
to six months right okay so maybe maybe
70,000 80,000 down whatever right but
with that much down what mortgage amount
of current mortgage rates which are
running about you know four and a half
on a 15-year roughly you know what does
that spit out to be a $1500 $1200 house
payment and you know that gives you some
guidelines and you're not going to be in
trouble with that you're not gonna be
quote unwise now you know the emotional
part is just out doing anything that you
do trying to quote normalize your life
with this much grief it just takes a
little while right it's just a process
and
so you know you know I get you know what
you might do is kind of anytime I'm
facing something I don't understand or
is new to me I try to read something
about it that's helpful
and so what popped into my head and it
has you probably have already done it
but if I'm just trying to think if I was
in your shoes and I can't even imagine
being in your shoes but I would read the
stages of grief and I would kind of give
myself a little bit of guideline and say
okay I'm gonna be in denial this pretty
tunnel and be angry this period of time
I'm gonna
and so by Christmas I'm gonna be ready
to look for a house or by Thanksgiving
I'm gonna be ready to look for a house
or by Halloween I'm gonna be ready look
for a house or now I'm ready because
I've already kind of gone through that
or whatever you know it's not to say
you're ever going to be completely over
this you probably want your whole life
it'll be part of your life you know it's
part of your story now and you don't
want to forget that wouldn't be right
but but there is a healing to where you
can breathe better one day then you
breathe it's another day does that make
sense I'm clearly so I mean I would get
where I can breathe good before I start
buying a house okay I was thinking yeah
and I don't know if it's seven I don't
think it's a year that doesn't make
sense to me I wouldn't wanna live with
my mother for a year you probably don't
you're probably ready to you know just
to close the chapter on the you know
close that chapter and move to the next
chapter so it would also be okay to rent
for six months and just heal that would
be an okay thing it just creates a
double move as always for furniture so
we sold most of it we have a tiny
storage unit I'm a garage sale bargain
hunter type person so most everything we
sold was Stefan I got guard cells and
honestly we made money on it after
living on it for three years so we kept
the the furniture that we want new what
do you want you for you what's your
husband and you between your husband and
you the two of you I mean when do you
feel like you ought to buy when you feel
like your heads going to be clear enough
to do that we kind of talked about the
new year like you said we kind of talked
about what starting to look in January
between now and then we can say probably
another twenty twenty-five thousand so
I'm not worried about that part I'm
worried about your broken heart
yeah that's all i margall I want to just
give you a pop broken hard time to heal
a little in January sounds good that
sounds feels wise everything's cool
living the way you're living there's no
toxic environment no weirdness there
with all this so it's a nurturing
environment for this time of and it's
been extremely helpful because we do
have a four year old so the live-in help
and everything's helpful oh we've got
we've got five grandkids under four when
they're all together one of them is in
meltdown at all times so yeah
everything's helpful oh that's the truth
well that's okay yeah you got some you
got some good backstop you got grandma
all there to help and grump all there to
help and give yourself a little time and
first of the year we're going to kick
into gear again and that's when we'll
turn the page the rest of the way and
then we'll just have some time to have
Thanksgiving giving thanks and have
Christmas and to have some celebrations
I like that I'm with you okay that feels
good I like that and not thought that
you need my permission you don't but and
then when you do it do a 15-year fixed
where the payments no more than a fourth
oh you take-home pay regardless of
whatever your down payment is okay thank
you
hey thanks for the call I'm so sorry for
your loss I can't even imagine Wow